嫌だアアアァ！！！！！
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
あの、ちょっと記事見たんすけどーすごい記事がありました！
こいつはもうやるしかねえみたいな
ドミノピザさんは皆さんよく食べますでしょうか
なんか今ドミノピザさんで限定の商品が売ってるみたいでございます
すげえ！
すげえ！w
ウルトラピザ
あっ違えわ
ドミノピザ、え〜ウルトラ盛り４倍チーズピザというのがやってるみたいでございます
なんか普通の、あのドミノピザのこうピザがあるんですけども、
こんなデカくねえか
ドミノピザのピザがあるんですけども、それのチーズが４倍になってるのがあってなんか
滅茶苦茶すごいって超話題になってるんで…
買います！！！
早速電話しましょう
（くしゃみ）
あっすいません、えっとピザのー注文をしたいんですけどー…
ドミノピザさん）はいお持ち帰りでしょうか、配達でしょうか
あっ配達でお願いします
ドミノピザさん）はい
で、あのーなんか今期間限定の
ドミノピザさん）ウルトラ…４倍盛りチーズ…
ウルトラ４倍盛りチーズ…を頼みたいんですけど大丈夫ですか
ドミノピザさん）はい、大丈夫です
ドミノピザさん）そうですねーできないです…
はい
てことは
４倍以上ってことですか
ドミノピザさん）そうですね
すごいですか？
ドミノピザ）結構すごいですねー…
結構すごいですかw
じゃ、じゃあダブルチーズ盛りを、足していただいてもいいですか
ドミノピザさん）あ、全然大丈夫です
すいませんありがとうございます…！
ウルトラ盛りチーズと、えっとウルトラ盛りチーズの
チーズトッピングしてあるやつ…
ドミノピザさん）ウルトラ盛りチーズと、あの追加ダブルチーズっていうことで…
あっそうです
はいっ
はいっわかりました
はい、すいませんっよろしくお願いします
ドミノピザさん）はいっ失礼いたします
はい
やば！４倍盛り超えちったぁ！！
なんかネットで見たんすけど、なんか４倍以上みたいな記事があったんすよ
もう４倍がとりあえずすごいすごいって言われてて
トッピングで更にチーズがのせれるんで
そうするとこれ６倍なのかなー
すげぇチーズ…
のせれましたわw
というわけで僕注文したのは、ウルトラチーズ盛りと
ウルトラチーズ盛りに更にチーズを足したやつを頼んでみました
ウルトラチーズ盛りもそもそもすごいと思うんですけど更にチーズチーズ足してみたんで
こっちがどうなるかっていうのをちょっと実際に食ってみたいと…思います
待ちます！！
はいっありがとうございまーす
ドミノピザさん）ありがとうございます！
あざしたっ
ドミノピザさん）あざっす、失礼しますっ
あっしたっ
ありゃとござぁしたっ
しゃっしゃ！
あっしたー！！
届きました〜！！！
わーこれもうどっちがどっちだかわかんないなぁ
でもこれが多分間違いなく
ドミノピザ史上
最も
チーズが乗っている
最強のピザでございます
どっちかが４倍でどっちかが４倍以上
多分６倍なんだよなー
ネットだと６倍って書いてあったんで
では早速、開けてみましょう
どっちがどっちかわかんないな、多分こっちが
アメリカンスタイルですわ〜
w
まままままままぁ
てことはこっちが？
ふぅーーー…
ピザじゃねぇ〜〜！w
これピザじゃないでしょ！w
ご覧ください！
こっちが多分４倍で、
こっちが更にちょっと気持ち多くなってるってかもう、なんか、
ピザじゃないっすわ！
やばこれーー
多分チーズ好きの方だったらたまんない一品だと思うんですけれどもー
えげつねぇな！
てか具が無いし肉ものってないし僕にはアウトです
あずぁざす！
４倍もまあ、まあ多いなと思ったんですけども…
もうチーズでしかない…
待ってカロリーが気になるな、ちょっとカロリー調べてみます
えっと４倍の方のカロリーがー
（過呼吸）
１５４４キロカロリーです
てことはこっちもうどうなんの！？
僕の推定だと多分２０００近くあるのではないかなと予想しております
オ゛ァ゛ッ
じゃとりあえず食べてみましょう…いただきやす！！
待って待ってw
はみ出しもいいところよ
いただきます
（かぶりつく音）
♪ 威風堂々
とんでもねぇチーズ感だ
チーズ好きからすると、死ぬほど美味しい一品だと思います
僕そもそも結構チーズ信者なんで
チーズだけのってても滅茶苦茶美味しいって感じるタイプなんです
たまんないです！
待って、これの更にチーズのせるってことはこっちもう大変なことになってると思いますよ
食べてみましょう
ぅはう〜ふふw
いやおかしいからもうw
生地に対してのチーズの厚さがやばい
チーズ好きはこれ大歓喜でしょじゃあ
ﾎﾜｯｯﾀﾞｱﾌﾞﾈｰﾍﾞ!!!!!
じゃあちょっと６倍食べてみます
いただきます
（かぶりつく音）
♪ 威風堂々
おほほほほほほww
４倍も全然多いんですけどー
やばい！まじで
この断面のチーズの厚さを感じて欲しいです
もうやばいんすよ！
多分もう…一人じゃちょっ、食え…ますけど
一回食べてみて
たなっち）え、でも美味しそうですね
たなっち）これチーズですよね
チーズです
たなっち）や、やば！チーズww
ちょ、パクッと食って、感想を教えてください
たなっち）わかりました
たなっち）チーズです
w
たなっち）でも美味しい
たなっち）美味しかったです、じゃあ…
たなっち）お疲れ様でしたw
たなっち）ありがとうございましたw
♪ エンディング
皆〜〜夜ご飯だよ〜
バナナじゃねぇwwwww